bonjour thierry amouroux merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
si le régulateur européen vallée de la
vaccin astrazeneca qu'elle suit ça va
dissiper les doutes ou la méfiance sera
toujours là ça va dépendre de la
réaction de la population mais il était
important de pouvoir faire une pause de
faire une étude de scientifiques de
façon à rassurer la population après cet
enchaînement de décision sur astrazeneca
des autres pays on pouvait pas laisser
penser que le nuage de tchernobyl
s'était arrêté à notre frontière
donc au nom du principe de précaution il
favorite et à l'info a attiré amoureux
puisque ça tombe à l'instant leurs
régulateurs européens estiment que le
vaccin astrazeneca n'est pas associée à
un risque plus élevé de caillots
sanguins selon la directrice de l'agencé
européenne du médicament
ça va me trouver à l'instant vous êtes
notre invité on en parle ça tombe au bon
moment votre réaction
c'était une étape nécessaire
il y avait besoin de rassurer la
population
après tout cet enchaînement de choses ça
faisait beaucoup de choses autour de ce
vaccin et il était important qu'une
parole scientifique s'exprime
parce que malheureusement la parole
gouvernementale n'a plus sa crédibilité
depuis un an lorsque les masques n'était
pas nécessaire finalement et sont
devenus obligatoires enfin bon voilà
donc c'était bien qu'il puisse y avoir
une parole scientifique indépendante
européenne pour rassurer la population
et en particulier la population
française la directrice de l'agencé
européenne des médicaments emea cook
vient de déclarer également à l'instant
je cite le vaccin astrazeneca est sûre
et efficace
ça ne va pas
quand même dissiper les doutes je vous
rappelle il ya eu un sondage récent est
là pour bfm tv 20 % des français n'ont
pas confiance dans le vaccin astrazeneca
contre 52% qui ont confiance dans le
vaccin preiser bio and take alors et
heureusement la stratégie vaccinale de
la france repose plus sur le finder pour
astrazeneca
vous avez beaucoup plus de deux doses de
father qui avait été précommandée que
d'astrazeneca et et donc vous avez 10
millions de doses de files heures qui
vont arriver le 5 avril et le 10 autres
millions qui sont prévues ou admet donc
du coup ça veut dire que cette annonce
du régulateur européen
savard assuré le gouvernement français
en attendant les annonces sur
confinement pas confinement pour
l'ile-de-france les niveaux de france 2
jean castex et d'olivier verrons tout à
l'heure
cette annonce du régulateur européen
savent a conforté le gouvernement dans
sa stratégie vaccinale
oui il est important de se vacciner à
astrazeneca et est un accès correct qui
répond parfaitement aux besoins de la
population
nommé il y avait besoin d'être rassurés
par une autorité indépendante
c'est ce qui a été fait l'a cette fois
ci par contre sur le lieu confinement là
encore on est quand même confronté en
france à un gouvernement assez
irresponsable quand ils communiquent
pour dire ben c'est un jour de plus de
gagner
nous soignons ce qu'on voit c'est que ce
sont des vies en plus de perdu et c'est
ça qui est terrible
regardez au niveau des établissements
scolaires en ile de france vous avez 555
classes qui sont le fermer comptez ne
pas prévoir des purificateurs d'air dans
toutes les classes
à l'exemple de
ce que fait l'allemagne depuis des mois
ne pas faire des 2000 groupe dans toutes
les classes avec un ennemi groupe avec
un enseignant et un autre demi groupe
avec un étudiant en master qui gère les
travaux pratiques les études dirigées
etc
c'est assez irresponsable de la part du
gouvernement on sait bien le
l'importance de la contamination via les
établissements scolaires je me permets
de revenir sur la communication la deûle
agence européenne du médicament sur le
vaccin astrazeneca est ce que vous vous
avez été vaccinées si oui est ce que
vous avez reçu une dose du vaccin
astrazeneca ou certains de vos collègues
et comment ont-ils réagi alors moi je
fais partie des des 70 ni soignant de
l'hôpital et 55000 soignants des ehpad
et des ime qui ont été contaminés par le
coffee et qui donc ont eu dans un
premier temps la consigne de ne pas se
vacciner en attendant les études et la
dernièrement la haute autorité de santé
qui a dit que j'allais attendre six mois
entre l'infection et une injection d'une
dose unique de deux vaccins
c'est d'ailleurs à très insultant pour
les soignants de qu'on leur est reproché
dernièrement de ne pas être assez
vacciner parce qu'il y avait déjà cette
équipe de population y allait également
le le fait que dans un premier temps
elle est bâclé les vaccins n'étaient pas
prévus pour pour les soignants puis deux
enceintes sont contents c'était réservé
aux soignants de plus de 50 ans et
c'était du freezer et là ça a été ça a
très bien marché
les trois quarts des vaccinés étaient
des soignants et simplement un quart des
patients
maintenant on est et restera zeneca pour
les soignants de tous âges
effectivement il y a des réticences des
soignants liée au fait que nous sommes
une catégorie particulièrement exposés
d'une part en terme de fréquence parce
que toutes les semaines on y confronter
à des patients porteurs du duc au vide
et d'une part d'autre part en charge
virale parce que les patients plan
rencontre à l'hôpital c'est des gens qui
ont une forte charge virale parce que
s'ils nécessitent d'être hospitalisé
c'est qu'ils ont la forme grave du duc
au vide et est donc
astrazeneca est un bon vaccin pour la
population générale mais c'est pas le
plus adapté pour pour les soignants
parce qu'il ya une faible efficacité en
particulier sur le variant sud africain
dernière question tirée amoureux dans le
cas où astrazeneca ne respecteraient pas
ces contraintes d'approvisionnement
quelles conséquences selon vous pour
l'union européenne et pour la france
surtout
alors le souci que contout les pays
c'est le manque de vaccins parce
qu'effectivement elle et les doses
jusqu'à présent quel que soit le le
laboratoire arrivent au compte gouttes
donc c'est la difficulté que l'on
rencontre néanmoins en france on
accumule une complexité supérieure avec
toute la technostructure des agences
régionales de santé qui font que déjà on
n'a pas énormément de doses mais en plus
il ya toujours eu deux à trois millions
de doses de vaccins qui sont quelque
part dans le circuit de la
technostructure et qui n'arrive pas au
bon centre de vaccination au bon moment
si vous regardez sur le site du
gouvernement le nom
deux millions de doses arrivée et nombre
de millions de doses de l'injecter jour
après jour vous voyez qu'il ya ce
différentiel de 2 à 3 millions de doses
qui restent dans les circuits de la
technostructure merci tirer amoureux
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le porte parole
du syndicat infirmier sn pays